there's no sound in the wild that is as
amazing as they rolled a lion
in Zambia we had so many stories about
them growing up how just hearing them
roll can bring down an entire manhood I
was young I used to be out of stories
about Laila's how they eat people other
stories were about how they just wanted
to kill for the sake of it but when I
grew up I found out that that was not
true when I was 13 I got involved with
my school's conservation Cub and that's
where I got to learn about the different
issues affecting wildlife
I myself Antonia where we all were in
the conservation Club and that changed
our minds you just see the world in a
different way we having an impact on
these species saying they're gentle and
it's up to us to do something about it
so then that's when he decided to pursue
a career in the wildlife side
a group of lions that we heard were in
the area when we locate them we want to
pass this information on to the lion
anti snaring team so that they can come
to the area check it for snares and
prevent any lions from getting caught
Lions in Zambia they're being threatened
by human related impacts and so
populations have been declining in some
places Lions are locally extinct there's
a whole lot of problems in our
communities poverty for example leads
people to go out and set lioness in the
bush the snares that I used a
non-selective so lions can walk into
those snares and get trapped the animal
can choke to death or get an infected
wound
if we can't find them today it
consequences are pretty serious because
this area is usually used by poachers as
well for push mix I will keep listening
for a while and try to get a location
it's difficult to you know act
responsibly when you haven't eaten I
think that's the most difficult thing we
need to find a way of balancing human
needs as well as our natural environment
if we the local people are directly
involved in conservation it could be a
very big success because we know the
area we know what sort of resources are
there we know what to eat we know what
we don't eat so we could try by all
means to find another way of doing
things
just before we cross over and go into
the park I'm just going one of the
things we do is take students into the
park we teach the students how to
collect scientific data and how to use
different pieces of equipment that help
that for you to get the location you
hate mud it's pretty fun for them
we also want to impart practical skills
that these students can use later on
career-wise it opens up new
possibilities it's important to
introduce them to our life early and
just show them these species in a more
different light then they become more
compassionate and responsible when it
comes to the interactions that they have
with these animals this because I get to
know some of the new animals like that
the war dogs and some of them you are
the first time to see them like that the
hope is that many of them should have a
high forward life it is our
responsibility as ambience to take
charge and protect to these animals to
see what life is a renewable resource if
we preserve them nicely we are going to
have them indefinitely
like she's having a sweet little lap in
the sand makes me really really happy to
find this line alive and healthy
she would have died without intervention
from said CP in cooperation with
conservation South Wang hua and the
Department of National Park
the work that I'm doing with my
colleagues is creating a generation of
people that are working towards the
protection of these species where the
people that live with these species and
we are responsible for making sure that
we survive side-by-side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you